Benvenuti alla terza puntata di temptation highland vip
Occupiamoci subito di Valeria e Patrick nel villaggio delle fidanzate una stellare e
sportivissima Valeria si lascia convincere dalle bel spagnolo Ivan ad un allenamento molto duro
dritto scendi scendi così
così sali bene
Mamma mia che dolore
10 dieci volti così brava
no ma guarda che corpo che cioè io non ti posso guardare veramente mi devo distrarre
per Patrick invece è tempo di pineto quello che vedrà gli darà finalmente un forte scossone
Però tu te senti sola
se una tigressa sola
tu non sei sola perché adesso stai con me
tu merita un uomo che prenda posizioni
la prendiamo la prendiamo
di un uomo che ti se fa prendere nel modo giusto
sei molto maturo per la tua età complimenti
perché mi ha portato qua per farmi vedere sta roba qua
io non voglio una bambina se lei ha voluto fare questo percorso per farmi vedere sta roba qua bene
brava complimenti
baci stellari addii stellari
lasciamo il povero Patrick ai suoi pensieri e occupiamoci
invece di Andrea Zenga e la sua fidanzata Alessandra
lui fa un lavoro che non gli piace dice che si sente inutile nella sua azienda
solo che titolare il padrino gli cambia niente dargli lo stipendio
Regà a sputtanata generale dice che mi mamma rompe sempre coglioni che sono viziato che lo faccio mai nulla
Dopo due settimane si è svegliata
è arrivato il momento del falò delle fidanzate
fidanzate benvenute a un altro falò
Valeria vorrei incominciare da te perché ho un filmato per te
finalmente
Il problema di Valeria è che lei ha dei difetti
questi difetti sono il fatto che lei non sappia stare da sola
che abbia sempre bisogno una persona accanto capito cioè io ho il mio lavoro
non posso farmi stipendiare da lei se lei ha bisogno di un'assistente si prende un assistente finita lì io non voglio fare il suo assistente
beh sì ma quello che mi dispiace che lui non ha capito niente
Mi sembra un discorso molto riduttivo lui parla solo del personaggio dal mio lavoro
non ha capito che la nostra relazione si deve basare su dei sentimenti
io ho bisogno di sentirmi amata
non lo so se Patrick sa cos'è l'amore
appena arrivata nel villaggio delle fidanzate Valeria è furiosa come
un coguaro e si sfoga con I suoi compagni di viaggio
no un coglione guarda proprio un cretino
falso come Giuda si merita delle corna guarda che pare proprio un cretino
cretino cretino cretino cretino con 14 cr
è il momento del risveglio e del villaggio dei fidanzati fin dal primo mattino il re leone Sossio
reagisce così
Occupiamoci ora di una coppia molto amata di tempetation island vip sto parlando di Nilufar e Giordano fate bene attenzione
perché siamo di fronte a una svolta
giordano sta per affrontare il suo falò dopo aver visto nilufar
vicinissima al singoli nicolò ferrari
giordano ti ho visto molto taciturno in questi giorni molto riflessivo
sì perché ho capito che io so entrato qua per risolvere dei problemi lei invece sta a distrugge tutto per la seconda volta
giordano ho filmato per te
immaginiamo
Secondo me è una coppia che non durerà è  quella di Nilufar e Giordano
Vale tu pensi che a Nilufar piaccio un po'
voi siete perfetti insieme ma gliel'ho detto anche a nilufar
quando scelto giordano ci sono rimasto troppo male
poi me ne sono fatto una ragione
però quando ci siamo ritrovati qua cioè era come se non avesse mai scelto giordano poi le ricerca cioè circa le mie attenzioni
Questa è la canzone della prima esterna nostra
basta
basta perché ho sentito troppo ho visto troppo e mi sento preso per il culo
voglio un falò
de confronto immediato se non me ne vado stasera stessa
quindi vuoi falò di confronto anticipato questa sera
si simo ora subito se non me ne vado stasera stessa
vediamo quello che riusciamo a fare giordano
ragazzi devo parlare un attimo con nilufar
Nilufar giordano ha chiesto un falò di confronto immediato
Madonna santissima mi sta venendo un infarto
Io ti aspetto al falò
Cosa ha visto cosa ha visto cosa ho visto
cosa ha visto che fermi fermi fermi fermi cosa ha visto cosa ha visto perché immediato perché immediato
allora giordano sono andata al villaggio ho parlato con Nilufar e gli ho detto che tu vuoi il confronto immediato quindi
aspettiamo insieme e vediamo se lei accetterà o meno di venire al confronto
Ma che è normale tutta sta attesa
Non ci sto capendo niente
A tu eh
al'ora o non c'ho capito un cazzo io fino ad ora ho mai solo preso per il culo
no e che cosa avresti visto
incoerenza
se è entrata qui dentro e stavi a piangere
ti ho visto tutti I giorni di spensieratezza
assoluta
l'ultima cosa che dovevi fare la parla con nicolò l'ultima
mi fai parlare un secondo mi hanno preso tutti per il culo
perché non facevo altro che parlare di te della tua schiena
oh famme parlà a tutti questi atteggiamenti che c'è come te li devi levà  mi devi fa parlà
sei innamorato sni ha risposto sni
mi pare che le dimostrazioni ce ne ha avute anche tante
io ho dormito tutte le notti con le  lettere che t'avevo scritto
ma che te parli con Nicolò
dei cazzi nostri
giordano
giordano che giordano che dopo tutto quello che è successo sai che cosa che dovevi a Nicolò ferrari ah vatti a  fa due passi da un'altra parte
e invece no sulla panchina parlare con lui
nicolò portami un deca ma un deca de che ma che ti fai porta
non gli posso chiedere un caffè
no nicolò non glielo poi chiede come non ci poi cantà
perfect la canzone della prima esterna nostra o non la canti non la canti
parlavo solo ed esclusivamente di te del nostro rapporto solo di questo
te diceva sai quante cose abbiamo in comune
e sai cosa gli ho detto
l'amore non funziona così
io me ne faccio niente una persona uguale a me io voglio diversa la questione di con la ferrari è stata chiusa 15 di maggio
io sono sicurissima dei miei sentimenti e tutte le persone che conosco lo sanno
ok giordano ti faccio io una domanda
tu sei innamorato di Nilufar
se io sono passato sopra una roba del genere è un motivo ci sta
io ti ho chiesto subito il falò del confronto un motivo ci sta
e non mi guarda cosa faccia che lo sai che sono innamorato di te stupida
o ce l'abbiamo fatta a far dire ti amo a giordano
ecco allora io ho la domanda di rito giordano vuoi uscire da solo o con Nilufar
ero quasi convinto di uscire da solo
non ci riesco
amore mio grande
Ecco l'amore è bello se litigarello solo un po' però eh
buona fortuna ragazzi per nilufar e giordano il viaggio nei sentimenti
termina qui
lasciano temptation island vip più consapevoli e più sicuri del loro amore
nel villaggio delle fidanzate c'è qualcuno che piange sto parlando del single niccolò ferrari che ancora una volta
sperava di far breccia nel cuore della bella Nilufar a consolarlo ci pensa la nostra valeria
Mi innamoro sempre di quelle sbagliate
Ma ti sei visto che bello che sei
cioè non ti manca veramente niente ti manca solo il mantello è il cavallo bianco per essere un principe azzurro
fortunata beata chi ti starà con te guarda
siamo giunti al termine della terza puntata
la prossima sarà l'ultima tappa del nostro viaggio nei sentimenti
se non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e lasciatevi un bel like
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social per rimanere sempre aggiornati e per vedere tante altre imitazioni ma
soprattutto ricordate di spiare il vostro amore ma ascoltare sempre sempre sempre il vostro cuore
alla prossima puntata